Hello and welcome to the final video in our series
and this is just finishing off exercise four.
For this we are going to be generating some custom points.
So what we've been working with up to this point is the grid setting.
Now the problem that this gives us is that sometimes it's going to select bad or select in
this corner because we have no concept of being next to a wall.
Now there are some things that we could do inside of the query itself.
However it's difficult to know the facing direction of the walls.
What I'm going to do in this is you can see that I have an ETQ hiding spots and this is
of the glass environment query generator. So if I wanted to create one of these
I'd come under blueprints and or we type in generator and you'd see that there is an
environmental query generator blueprint base. You could use this to create your own.
But let's have a look at the one that I've already created.
Now this is relatively complicated as far as it comes from the code.
But what's important is we are overriding the function doItemGeneration
and on the return node there is no output pin but it is the add generated vectors.
These are going to be the generated points that we want to check.
Now this does mean a number of things but fundamentally what it's doing is it is doing
a line trace in a large circle from outside of the character pointing inwards.
Meaning that we are going to hit any wall which is facing the character.
Now you can go through this if you want but it is a little bit complicated.
So I'm not going to go through it here. The main point is we are filtering out
we're finding vectors that meet our criteria. So let's save that and let's use that inside
of the engine. So I'm going to come back down to our find hiding spot.
I'm going to move our hiding spot thing to the right here and disconnect it.
I'm going to drag down and I'm going to select generator again.
But this time I'm going to use the ETQ hiding spots.
I hit save. We can look at this and you can see that what this is doing
is this is generating spots around the character on the outside of the walls.
So it's trying to figure out the good hiding spots that we have.
Now I exposed some variables and they can be used as the controls.
On the controls, on the elements. But I'm all right with the defaults at this point.
However, I do need some tests. So I'm going to drag them across.
I want past exists. And I'm not so worried about the context,
the trace on visibility because this is done in the generation of the points.
However, I am going to use the dot product and I am going to use the distance to crew.
If I say and have a look at these points, you can now see that we have filtered out
the points here and we have maintained the points around these sides here.
So you can see this is quite a good hiding spots here.
And those are going to be the ones that are selected because they are away from the player.
I'm 100% sure I like these ones on the edge.
Might be able to get rid of them by playing around with some of the settings.
So I am going to distance to check from the left to right.
I'm going to change that to A2. Save.
And see if that changes our settings a little bit.
It's pushing them back a little bit so that we are not having ones right at the edge.
I'm going to even push it out a little bit further and see how that works.
Let's go 200.
Yep, that's better.
That's killed the ones at the sides.
But it's also killed the ones up here because it's quite large.
But let's go with that for the top view.
Okay.
So if I press play at this point, you can see that they run off and find a hiding spot.
And they're only ever hiding behind something that can see it.
So if I run up here, you can see that they go and find the nearest
hiding spot just around the corner.
As soon as they can see me, they're running away and hiding again.
So this just programmatically finds spots and hides from the player.
And with that, it brings us to the end of this course.
Hopefully you found that useful and can fully utilize the Perception and EQS system.
Thank you very much.